much and as we switch into recovery mode
is it time to ask Falchi and birx
to continue their work but maybe not do
these daily briefings Politico is
reporting that the white house is
shifting its communications focus from
kovat containment and mitigation to
reopening the country which includes
managing the media bookings of
government experts like deborah birx
and anthony foul a White House press
secretary Kelly mcenany is overseeing
this effort she joins us now Kelly are
you guys putting the docs on in a box
what's going on there it's like a dr.
Seuss book what's that
you know no that's not the case what we
do each and every day is we ask
ourselves what announcements do the
American people need to hear about what
is the next iteration of the news
stories as we move forward on amid this
pandemic and look toward reopening the
economy and that's what guides us and
some days that means dr. Burks and dr.
fell to being out there other days that
means Kevin Hassett Steve minuchin I'm
in the economic team so really what the
American people need to hear is what
guides us and Kelly a lot of folks are
just anxious for good news they don't
want to have blind faith but they want
good news they want optimism going
forward that's American spirit
dr. Fatih was talking about what could
be coming however watch if we are
unsuccessful or prematurely try to open
up it could be much more than that it
could be a rebound to get us right back
in the same boat that we were in a few
weeks ago it's inevitable that we will
have a return of the virus or maybe it
never even went away is that a review
that the White House shares that it's
inevitable that we can see into the
future that this virus will definitely
come back if if if if if this state
opens a little earlier that state opens
but not according to exactly the plan of
the White House look you know President
Trump has put forward these phased
reopening guidelines you know governors
are following them I mean it's up to the
governor's ultimately what to do but
look the president's very impressed with
a lot of these plans that he's seen
today we had Ron DeSantis and the
governor of Florida a great example of a
state that's just doing it right
it's reopening the economy this
president is leading the way every step
of the way he's made the right decision
and he's making the right decision now
to look toward a reopening the economy
you're exactly right the American people
want optimism they want confidence and
that is exactly what President Trump is
giving them there was a really cool trip
by vice president pence today to the
Mayo Clinic where he was looking into
all this new plasma technology that
might be very useful in fighting this
virus as we go forward and maybe if it
does come back in the fall but the media
had a different focus check it out Vice
President Mike Pence are raising concern
as he visited the famed Mayo Clinic in
Rochester Minnesota
and was the only person seen not repeat
not wearing a mask is this Mike Pence
figuring out that Trump has decided that
masks are for people in his role a form
of weakness this is Mike Pence cowering
to a president who doesn't think masks
are for him
Kelley your thoughts on mask shaming
yeah it's ridiculous you know we're all
routinely tested for coronavirus in the
White House the media obsession with
Mike Pence wearing a mask
is really just ridiculous what they need
to be focused on is talking to the
American people covering what the
president does in the White House each
day these small business loans that have
been remarkable that have saved
companies all of the health updates we
have instead of focusing on mass palace
masks palace intrigue perhaps they can
focus on delivering news to the American
people I think that's what the American
people deserve hey Kayla are you gonna
be doing press conferences your
predecessor didn't didn't do the press
conferences will you be doing them as
time goes on we move into this post
kovat world we hope hey i gaggle with
the press you know almost every day and
look that's up to the president but
right now the American people are
hearing directly from President Trump
and there's no better messenger than the
President of the United States
all right Kelly thanks for stopping by
come back soon thank you Laura